and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bomb
tonight's review the secret word of
Arrietty
oh my god the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
would you mind if I borrowed some
spoilers there's this little girl named
avi T only I don't mean little like
she's very young more like she's the
size of Danny DeVito's testicle and
Sheila's would father Danny DeVito
testicles inside this really nice house
where they borrow things will not really
borrow them praise you give it back I'm
not really sure how you borrow sugar eat
it and then give it back I want to leave
there is one way but you wouldn't make
it
so idiots he comes across this Sick Boy
and she's like afraid of me know what
it's a Miyazaki film we're never
surprised by anything two girls wrote
inside a cat that was a bus and that
baby got a reaction music he's weird yes
but he is also awesome but because they
were seen by the boy they suddenly have
to move and here he is like oh because
that boy saw no there are so few of us
that we cannot take the risk of being
found out by the human beings you know
yeah we always say that in movies but
what I did just go to the human beings
that use their science and technology to
find out if there's more we could
befriend them we could exchange these
dangerous species and something else
would be going green nobody wears
contacts no close-minded refusal to
understand others it's the best way to
go your toy well the girl can't help but
keep up her relationship with the boy
it's kind of like Twilight only we give
a crap but then we find out that the
little boy is dying
oh you're dying yes however I am going
through an operation they say there's a
very slim chance that it could help you
live don't you cut you know that anytime
a character's going through an operation
they always come out okay not always
fine okay shut the hell up bitch but it
turns out that Yvonne housekeeper finds
one of the powers so she borrows her and
puts her in a jar she also locks the boy
in the room because that's what a good
housekeeper does to dine kids but area
tea helps him get out and they save the
mother and the housekeeper's like people
here share their way by pulling my ear
off sure I'm fired aren't I yes you are
so the voice says goodbye the area TS he
goes off with her family and we're just
wondering if the little boy will ever
survive his operation oh wait he does
well we're off to see all of the other
powers that exist in this way
funny that there'd be a little bit more
to this movie like how the kids dealing
with almost dying or all the other
places that the Bauer's come across
their new home the animals they tried to
fight off they talk about all the
dangers of the world and the only thing
they come across is Carol Burnett is a
dwarf green tip it's a noodle framing it
smack it bar oh yeah Arrietty is that a
great movie it teaches us so much like
if you see little people you're not
necessarily a drug that's something I
really need to hear this is just to eat
them sing
yeah William Jay
come on I use it to make a live-action
version with John Goodman it'll be a
huge hit